hey everybody time once again for the
Kaiser report lovely season
hey max we're gonna to follow up on that
Ray Dalio story you mentioned Ray Dalio
is a multi multi billionaire he's I
guess he basically who finances all of
Connecticut and they're bankrupt state
he's a Connecticut hedge fund guy he
just donated two hundred million dollars
they're the largest donation ever to
Connecticut for their education system
but he was also in the news because of
course he did recently declare that
hedge fund billionaire a Dahlia says
capitalism is failing America and we
need to take five specific actions to
save it ray Dalio in a LinkedIn post
analyzes the ways America's economy has
been failing the majority of its
citizens and places the current
environment in a global perspective
he wrote that he's seen capitalism
evolve in a way that is not working well
for the majority of Americans because
it's producing self-reinforcing spirals
up for the halves and down for the
have-nots oh yeah I read this already a
Pisa it's a good analysis of why it's
systems not working but his conclusions
about the solutions favors the
benevolent dictator that's his number
one solution we need strong leaders to
impose a top-down you know change and of
course that's what got us into the
problem to begin with you have
benevolent dictators running the central
banks and Ray Dalio is one of the
biggest beneficiaries of essentially
having central bank's stuff money into
his pockets for years now he hasn't
worked a day in his life yeah I mean one
of the solutions that he offers warren
buffett offers that Bill Gates offers
that Jeff Bezos offers that every single
billionaire America says what we need is
more education better education but what
is education really when you have China
you know with 1.4 billion people or
India with 1.3 billion people and India
they all speak English fluently so they
could do any job that we can do
for much less right here he's again
here's what he identifies as the actual
problems the numbers that if you look at
it these are the problems right he says
Dalio listed reasons why capitalism
isn't working as it should in the u.s.
one there's been no real wage growth
adjusted for inflation for the majority
of Americans since 1980 the income gap
is high as if it's ever been and the
wealth gap is as high as it was in the
late 1930s ahead of World War two three
two-thirds of the bottom 60% have no
savings and economic mobility has been
declining for 40 years and for about
seventeen point five percent of children
live in poverty and despite some
outliers America's public education
system as among the worst in the
developed world
you won't hear Rachel Maddow or MSNBC
talk about this they'll keep on
parroting the line that Hillary said of
America's already great so when Donald
Trump identified that America is not
great anymore Ray Dalio who Connecticut
is a democratic state a blue state Ray
Dalio is saying exactly what Donald
Trump said on the campaign trail
essentially is the majority of Americans
are in this situation the majority of
Americans are not in a situation of
Hillary Clinton or her friends Ray Dalio
and Warren Buffett and Bill Gates
they're in this situation where they're
suffering and the you can either admit
this and then address it or you could
just keep on blindly pretending we're
already great and if you listen to
Rachel Maddow and you know things will
be great
well there's ignorance and there's
willful ignorance okay so when you have
Rachel Maddow
she's just ignorant she doesn't know
anything about economics he's a
financially illiterate same thing with a
lot of people on the Left like Amy
Goodman at Democracy Now has never had a
report on the economy that made any
sense in the 25 years she's been on the
air then there's a willful ignorance and
that would be Ray Dalio so Ray Dalio
he's not mentioning money gold or
interest rates
in his solutions at all that's willful
ignorance he knows in his heart of
hearts that the problem is the money
itself the US dollar is trash it's
garbage it's no good it's not a store of
value it's not a medium of exchange it's
it's a it's a it's a yuppie free tickets
you know he's to call him on Wall Street
when I was working on Wall Street used
to call them yuppie coupons you know
they're just they just pour out of the
bank essentially you know you know what
the work for him at all they just put
your 8-bit card in the machine and these
$20 bills pour out we don't work for it
that's Ray Dalio but he's billions of
dollars are pouring out of the ATM
called the central bank so it's
willfully ignorant to ignore the true
cause of all the problems that he
articulates and I suppose he's trying to
create a most you know around himself
from the the masses with the burning
torches when they come after people like
Ray Dalio he's trying to say no don't
shoot me so let's again go into more of
the details because he's saying
education it's you ordinary people who
are just too stupid to compete with me
we live in a meritocracy after all he's
continuing that lie that we live in a
meritocracy if only you got more
education you could be as brilliant and
rich as I am he's not talking about of
course these hedge funds in Connecticut
why they all live there is the carried
interest and the fact that their tax
rate is way lower than some Joe bag of
doughnuts or what did I call her Jane
pocket of Chris packet of crisps okay
that they have to pay taxes a tax rate
much higher as a percentage of their
income than the likes of Ray Dalio who
get to live you know off earned interest
part of being willfully ignorant is also
being willfully stupid and willfully
uneducated so there are millions of
people in America and around the world
who are better educated than Ray Dalio
but in order to succeed on Wall Street
you need to have complete lack of
empathy this has been proven in study
after study after study Ray Dalio has no
consideration about the effect he's
having on society and the work the
ruination of the lives that he's
contributing to by being a lead
the system with his hedge fund that's a
lack of empathy and it there that that
takes a certain kind of myopia and
stupidity to work yourself into that
state he you know is just benefiting
from the system just as Donald Trump
said he gave money to Hillary Clinton
because he knew the system is rigged he
could give a hundred million to her and
get benefits same with Ray Dalio but
they keep on saying it's just you have
to get education it's not just the tax
system it's not the cantle in effect
it's not the fact that he gets money
first from the Fed he gets access to
zero percent money and you don't it's
not the fact that you know going off the
gold standard we have no way to know
what the value of any money really is
like there are thousands of reasons it's
not Hillary Clinton's husband Bill you
know him getting rid of the
glass-steagall Act and the commodities
Modernization Futures Modernization Act
in 2000 and that we got to like
basically defraud everybody through
credit derivatives it's none of that and
of course the role of the dollar and and
that's my final headline here because
this was a remarkable story that again
got overlooked by you know MSNBC which
is supposed to be the channel the cable
news channel for the working class for
helping out the ordinary person
exclusive Saudi Arabia threatens to
ditch dollar oil trades to stop no Peck
so Saudi Arabia is threatening to sell
its oil and currencies other than the
dollar if washington passes a bill
exposing OPEC members to US antitrust
lawsuits three sources familiar with
Saudi energy policy said now of course
you know since we went off the gold
standard in 1971 we've been on a u.s.
dollar standard that's been you know
it's always treated as a conspiracy
theory that it's a you know we basically
back it by Saudi Arabia's oil but the
fact is to have the dollar as a global
reserve standard it requires massive
trade deficits and so at the end of the
day you have to recognize that that
means you the American worker lose you
can't win in that situation yeah true
but so I mean what's the question the
question is why is stati Arabia
threatening the US or is why is the US
dollar such
a weak currency I mean what's the I mean
yeah Saudi Arabia threatening the US the
u.s. is obviously something that when
you put it in the context of the last
two and a half years of the Russia
bashing that's come out of MSNBC
Washington Post The New York Times a
complete fabricated nonsensical story
versus an actual and existential threat
called Saudi Arabia then it's it's sad
because they've spent all their
journalistic firepower on a non-story in
lieu of a real story as far as a dollar
yeah it's backed by a country Saudi
Arabia so I mean that's not a great
currency situation either things work
for a while until they don't a business
cycle is booming for everybody until
it's not the recession happens right now
the US has been on the u.s. global US
dollar standard since 1971 and that
worked brilliantly
while the debt went up and up and up and
up and the average ordinary worker had
to lose because you needed to send more
dollars overseas which means you need to
import more than you export right so we
come at the endgame of that and what has
that has arisen is that China is a much
bigger importer of oil than the United
States
so Saudi Arabia's biggest client is it
is China China wants to pay them in un
because they don't want to have to pay
real money for the oil they want what
America's had is fake money they get to
print money they're yuan and pay for
this oil so the in China has provided
basically competition but think it's
like the concentration of billionaires
so you have u.s. Saudi in China so the
petro dollar epoch the started in the
early 70s you had a lot of US
billionaires become billionaires in the
banking sector and also in the
technology sector but the relative
strength of the Saudi billionaires was a
lot stronger the Saudi billionaires with
Aramco it's now it's been multi
trillion-dollar behemoth and so those
billionaires have been getting billion
area richer faster than the u.s.
billionaire so Saudis been happy because
they get the you know it's all about ego
right so their egos are stroked
bigger than the Americans oleg arks then
the Chinese oligarchs enter the picture
and they say wait a minute we want to
have our ego stroked in an incredible
way so the Saudis are saying well okay
we're the king of the roost our
billionaires are the biggest
billionaires of all let's try to squeeze
the us in favor of China and again it's
not like it they're not an ally I think
that would be a mistake every single
nation on earth our every single nation
is run by that's what happens power
corrupts and absolute power corrupts
even more but so we're not talking about
that we're just talking about that the
actual facts and what is happening and
the the likely cycle and in the unlikely
event Riyadh were to ditch the dollar it
would undermine the status of the dollar
as the world's main reserve currency
reduce Washington's clout and global
trade and weaken its ability to enforce
sanctions on nation states those are the
words of Reuters saying that it's not us
it's not you know gold bugs or anything
like that they're saying just the facts
and I think this is reflected on cable
news it's reflected in Ray Dalio they
see what's coming but they don't want to
address it because there's no solution
other than to like go on a global SDR or
gold or another standard which is
inevitably coming and they're scared
well there's always competition from
capitalism yeah and that's a rave Dalia
was saying can you end up with countries
run by in your words therefore to
understand the psychology and the
ego-driven masa nations of the gives one
an insight into the trends of the global
economy it's not a fact-based it's ego
based it's Freudian has been is will
continue to be unless there is true
competition
all right we have to take a break and
when we come back much more
[Music]
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser we're gonna return to our
conversation now Steve King he's the
author of debunking economics he's got a
patreon account now that is superb
people I know who check it out tell me
it's the best thing out there on patreon
I myself occasionally hack my way into
it and read it myself I don't give Steve
any money because I'm too cheap but I
have him on my show and I pick his brain
right now you see Steve welcome back
well thank you Todd walk very glad to be
alright so to carry on with our
conversation billionaire Ray Dalio was
on 60 minutes last week warning of the
revolution because capitalism has failed
do you agree what do we do well I think
capitalism can fail and the reason that
comes back to the climate change which I
knew the ardent fossil fuel capitalists
are trying to convince this doesn't
exist as we were staring down massive
climate change over else on the planet
in that situation if we actually find
holy hill we are destroying the planet
it was restoring our capacity to live on
the planet how do we reverse it that
will involve a wartime effort and in
that wartime effort will have rationing
of energy will have every every
available amount of energy being devoted
to creating non carbon-based energy
inputs all that sort of stuff will be
like a militarized version of capitalism
which we had back in the Second World
War it's still capitalist but it's so
far from the free market it ain't funny
and I think I think we do face that
fight economics generally deals with
scarcity and money tends to deal with
commodities that are scarce and we're
currently living in a world of zero
scarcity there's no scarcity of fiat
money
there's no scarcity in the environment
nope no major corporation no oil company
prices in a Peak Oil and by Peak Oil I
mean the price of extraction keeps going
higher and higher or in the case of
fracking it's a Ponzi scheme
that never was profitable from day one
and without these scarcities you can't
have capitalism Ray Dalio never mentions
any of this he simply says you know you
need to go to an Ivy League school learn
how to do a carry tray from Japan get
some free money and then pontificate
endlessly has 60 minutes and never work
a day in your life that's Ray Dalio
solution but nevertheless your point is
well-taken that climate change is going
to force rationing effectively and we're
going to see the price of stuff reflect
reality pretty soon that would be gas in
America at nine ten eleven dollars a
gallon or higher
that would mean prices moving higher so
we have as you say I believe it would be
stagflation right it would be economic
collapse with higher prices
Steve cave your thoughts possible Maxima
nothing wanted more likely to happen is
that when we realize we've got to
drastically reduce our energy footprint
on the planet that means less energy
being available for thriftless
activities and in forever this meaning
you know I mean I've just been since I'm
in Thailand and went shopping in so many
department stores to care about the
number of fancy faces I saw for the back
of iPhones is uncountable energy
rationing will strike at some point
it'll all be a case of devoting it to
building alternative energy inputs to
get about your consumer goods forget
about this forget about that it won't be
so much a price spike as a whole lot of
stuff that used to be available isn't
available anymore if you go back to the
Second World War and we find anybody old
enough to remember what it was like to
have to buy to drink coffee in those
days you weren't drinking coffee you're
drinking chicory a cheap substitute to
make it possible to have something
resembling the taste when the stuff
itself wasn't available I think that's
more likely our future but in when you
have a rationing system opposed it's
very hard to call that capitalist so I
think very Dalia is right in one sense
on that at capitalism's days are
numbered
because everybody has fundamentally
privatized their profits and social
their losses are those socialized those
losses into the ecosphere and we can't
allow that to go on indefinitely it will
all have no economy so yeah we're in for
a serious reversal
so energy rationing the theme and
basically that would dominate the
economy and to use your analogy you
would be basically on a war type economy
where it's really I guess you could say
dire in many respects now Steve Keen the
Fed has recently indicated that they
will go negative on rates should the
economy falter negative rates in Europe
have not encouraged banks there to lend
to businesses will they work in the US
Steve now they're a silly idea
I mean the whole idea of negative rates
as economists think that people are
hoarding money and therefore if you make
it expensive to hold money I'll spend
instead and that will stimulate the
economy it's not hoarding of money
that's caused it it's too much debt too
much of a debt overhang that's why
people aren't spending the negative
rates will encourage people to take
their money out of banks this is one of
the reasons a lot of central banks are
talking about eliminating cash so that
they can therefore impose negative rates
because you'd have nowhere for your
money other than an electronic bank
account I think that's one of the most
dangerous ideas possible because I don't
want people who don't understand
something being the right to control it
and am I sure with central banks is that
they haven't understood money because
they're staffed by mainstream economists
who wouldn't have a clue what a monetary
system is and yet they're trying to
control our access to money so I'm very
much against cadre of abolishing cash
and I think negative rates are a stupid
idea that shows how little economists
know about the real world well I have an
idea for you
thinking out of the box there get your
thoughts on it what what about idea of
money that's like a frequent flyer mile
and that it expires if you don't use it
it expires yes for a year if you wanted
to design a monetary system from the
scratch would you design one which has
money that doesn't decay and the answer
I think would be no because you want
money to circulate you think about the
functions of money one of the
fundamental transit functions of course
is transactions and that encouraged you
to spin now they're one of the other
fundamental functions a store of value
those magic you to not spend
and because we're has such an
accumulation of dead people are looking
more about the not spending side
accumulating there's pile of cash rather
than the spending who have actually had
that whole dynamic of a badly designed
monetary system meaning that the
economy's slowing down because of his
monetary system I would rather have a
monetary system where the money decayed
in the sense that gizelle spoke about if
he didn't spend it
there was a non transactions execution
tax imposed on your account that would
encourage you to do that turnover so I'd
rather have the money decay I'd rather
have a gazelian system if I was advising
Elon Musk about the monetary system for
Mars in 2030 after the engineers have
exhausted their central planning then
I'd go for I'd go for a gazillion money
system which would mean nobody could
accumulate enormous fortunes on Mars but
have to be spending the money they've
got and Mars would have a you know
booming economy using that as an example
a place you could start from a blank
slate there might be another benefit
here so to carry this on a little bit
you would be disincentivized to issue
bonds with 10 20 30 year maturities if
money expired before people had a chance
to pay the interest in the principle of
those bonds so you would have less than
debt of this right you'd have listened
ed Ennis you'd have the less asset
inflation I think a huge amount of
energy in intellectual energy and has
gone into financial engineering which
has given us a stressed over indebted
fragile social system rather than gone
into real engineering and build us a
robust physical economy so I'm young I'm
very much in favor of something that
reduces the power of the financial
sector reduces the amount of
accumulation of monetary wealth and
reduces the amount of debt as well
moving on OSC she's got her green new
deal that's choice one choice two would
be Donald Trump's campaign when he took
on the campaign trail of a trillion
dollar infrastructure spend which would
be better for the American economy or
door number three is another round of
quantitative easing Steve King get rid
of quantitative easing quantitative
easing has been to the benefit of the
wealthy it's been the gun
central bank deciding to be on the buy
side of bond purchases with the private
financial sector at the turn of a
trillion dollars a year which is more
than 5% of the American GAAP that money
has been spent when the when the bank's
got that that money in released that the
bonds they sold with the government they
used that money to buy shares that drove
up this price of existing shares people
rich people hold existing shares is
accentuated the inequality caused by the
financial bubble in the first place and
only a tiny trickle of that money's made
it into the real economy so I think for
every trillion dollars in you might have
got two hundred billion dollars out for
the for the Main Street rather than a
Wall Street when it's Main Street that
needs to be rebuilt not Wall Street
so forget about QE Trump's billion
dollar infrastructure I yes the America
needs infrastructure spending I know you
had a few bridges fall down recently
you've got massive hurricane damage
coming your way in many many states your
road system sucks you don't have the
high-speed rail China has a high-speed
rail so there's huge infrastructure
spending necessary but there's also the
green new deal and I think I'm on the -
given where we are in the I think
approach to a serious climate breakdown
I'd go with the green new deal but I can
see some need for the infrastructure
spending as well so now we're gonna go
geopolitical we're gonna go high level
Steve according to Reuters Saudi Arabia
recently threatened to start pricing
their oil and currencies other than the
dollar okay here's a big one Steve what
are your thoughts on this well I think
it's got to happen max I don't know that
Saudi Arabia's going to have to do it
frankly I think they'll probably back
out because they as much as they've got
America in their pocket they're also in
America's pocket so the threat to to
break that friendship could be
disastrous for the Saudis both
domestically and in their in their
political influence in their own sphere
but certainly I know China Russia along
with some European countries are looking
at bringing about an alternative
currency basket trading system and I
know turkey is looking at the same thing
for Islamic countries given the extent
to which Trump has used the American
dollar as a weapon for his form of
diplomacy so I think these are serious
threats
they'll probably take longer to come
into reality than any of them than we
expect they always find I anticipate
these things too soon and they happen in
a rush later than I expect so I think
maybe the next decade it'll happen I
understand what you're saying okay Saudi
Arabia would have to take a lot of
gumption to go against the petrodollar
relationship but the fact is that
they're already moving away from it
they've got a great relationship with
China now and economics would suggest
that the path of risk least resistance
would be to get out of this dollar
petrodollar relationship it just seems
that if they're gonna ever do it the
time to do it is is now so that could be
a major factor Steve I think that's
probably a slow drift rather than a
dramatic shift they can handle one or
two or three contracts they can just
invite our arrangements and stuff like
that they can do various swaps that end
up being in another currency so I think
it'll happen slowly and gradually but it
has to happen a huge part of the
economic houses of the last 70 years
have been because the American dollar
was the reserve currency all right Steve
Cain thanks for being on the Kaiser
report and Q max thank you so I see all
right and that's gonna do it for this
edition of the Kaiser report with me Max
Keiser and Stacy herbart like to thank
Steve keen and you absolutely must check
out his patreon account it's well worth
whatever he's charging I don't know what
it is but whatever it is it's a steal
and I don't say that lightly do you want
to catch us on twitter it's Kaiser
report until next time bye y'all
[Music]